the holidays can be stressful when it
comes to all the parties events family
but one thing makes it easier if that's
having wines and snacks that please
anyone who may be dropping by and here
to help us stock our fridges and bars
with all the right goodies is diana
breyer aka the wonder woman of cheese
and owner of anderson's beloved valley
cheese and wine welcome back diane it's
so good to have you thanks for having me
again okay so all of a sudden some
people knock on my door happy holidays
and i'm like i wasn't expecting you what
do i serve them yeah you know you don't
have to be as stressed and neither does
your budget
we actually have a few cheeses that i
consider staples during the holidays so
essentially you want to have a few
cheeses just always on deck okay soft
cheese a hard snacking cheese and what i
like to call a super cheese it's a
cheese that can be used in recipes great
for snacking great for grating on the
top of things so you'll always have
things on deck and then i also chose
three bottles that perfectly pair with
them that are all under twenty dollars
which means you can have guests come
over at the last minute and it doesn't
have to stress you out as much as you
might think okay so let's start with the
soft cheese here and what you pair it
with what do we have here so great rule
for the holidays great rule for soft
cheeses in general always go a brie and
a bubbly so this is fleur de nui it's
actually a shower style from france okay
and we paired it with a creme antiloir
now a kerman actually is made in the
same style as a true champagne but is
just from a different area of france oh
so this is from the loire valley um so
it's going to have a little chalky
minerality in the soil there but it's
actually just a beautifully approachable
bubbly it's on your left why don't you
give that okay so we've got this one and
then we got the breeze and you've got
that it looks like there's some
preserves with that there are so one of
the coolest things about cheese is that
it actually pairs really well with a
multitude of items that you probably
already have in your pantry so if you've
got a jam go ahead and stick one on the
board if you've got mustard mustard goes
with cheese too not a lot of people know
that one and honey is always going to be
a great accompaniment for any of your
harder or aged cheeses
so a little trick of the trade that
pairing is really good i really like the
the effervescence kind of after the soft
kind of thick cheese you know yes the
notion there is that the bubbles are
going to help sort of break up the
creaminess of the cheese and sort of
saturate the palette with all of that
delectable goodness that happens oh my
gosh that was so good okay i could just
live on that one but let's let's go to
the super this is the soup this is the
super cheese this is gruyere you may
have already heard of gruyere it's one
of the world's finest melting cheeses
it's often seen on top of french onion
soup but what not a lot of people know
is that gruyere can also be a wonderful
snacking cheese okay you've got some
mustard i've got mustard on it and
what's up this is actually an unoaked
chardonnay from california which is very
different to find usually you find a lot
of oak chardonnays but this one is going
to have like some beautiful like in the
gray air you'll get some nice sort of
savory tones your chardonnay is going to
give you light bright sort of stone
fruit notes and together they're just
going to play this like interesting sort
of palette dance i am shocked at how you
are able to pair these yes this was like
a tang here and this kind of settled it
down a little bit out of it wow okay we
only have 30 seconds left so let's end
here this is our heart
and you actually like this one in
october so i brought it back for you
because it goes really well with your
red wine which is a cabernet franc from
the loire valley okay and is that some
honey on top yep honey on top again
honey aged cheeses honey any sheep's
milk cheeses really really great pairing
little trick of the trade wow the honey
just completely adds a whole new element
to that yeah with the wine they're
telling me to wrap with the wine